you have Pink Floyd you got the who when
you think about the Beatles obviously
CDC yeah yeah you got all sorts of [ __ ]
you got a lot a lot going on back then
you know of course you have Hendrix John
Glenn jazz job at the doors yeah you got
a lot [ __ ] and then you got the weird
ones the Mamas and the Papas amazing
band wasn't there some weird [ __ ] that
went on with that family
well yeah but also heroin and cocaine
kind of killed all that hold that hold
music scene yeah there's a lot of that
that's the problem it's sort of starts
it up and then it poisons it well
psychedelics and we'd probably good fear
music when you get into cocaine and
heroin
music is gonna dying don't don't you
know I get it that it's bad for you but
I think it's there's it can't be a
coincidence
that so many people that love heroin
made amazing music beforehand though so
a lot of forehand yeah look at Lou Reed
any of them who got into heroin their
music stopped
Lou Reed was always even Hendrix and Jim
Morris I mean a lot of the songs that
Hendrix was writing me he died at 27
yeah so that was a relatively his
musical development I think was done
less with you know maybe maybe
psychedelics but I don't think heroin
played a factor until later on in his
life so um it's hard to say I mean I
don't know I know he was arrested in
Toronto with heroin I don't know the
whole history was I don't by that time
so famous he had already written those
songs they got him there you know maybe
yeah I mean I don't know when he started
using heroin or why yeah I don't think
heroin makes you more more artistic or
more successful at all but I think what
happens is you have very talented people
that have a substance abuse problem you
know that's what Steven killin King said
he said I'm great writer but I don't
remember writing Cujo yeah my alcohol
didn't make me a better writer I'm a
really imaginative talented writer who
happens to have a substance abuse
problem and a bit of it yes and no yes
and no cuz yes he is unbelievably
talented yes he's an amazing writer he's
one of my personal favorites I mean I
probably read more Stephen King books
and any other fiction author but the
stuff that he wrote when he was doing
drugs was hard-core [ __ ] he wrote The
Shining and Cujo and the Tommyknockers
he wrote all sorts of wicked books man
where there's just evil intentions and
ruthless actions and shocking scenes and
the fact it was a coincidence he was
doing coke just a coincidence he was
drunk
no I didn't listen wrote the books
though I think what they did no one's
saying that if you look vitamin C
doesn't make a person right it's these
are these are tools yeah to squeeze the
most out of your imagination while
suppressing any sort of a sort of
societal handcuffs you might have put on
yourself because of the horrific notions
like he said he would say things in his
book where you would go whoa like you
would have to take a step back like
where the [ __ ] like what what kind of
[ __ ] person thinks this up right what
kind of person I'll tell you what kind
of person a guy who's drunk as [ __ ]
doing coke who's also a great writer
it's not that writing that stuff and
digging into his I'm not saying that I
think you probably could have achieved
the exact same results on the natch
because he's Steven [ __ ] okay it
might have focus is my firm it's also
it's also positive possible rather that
that stuff is rocket fuel it's rocket
fuel for your your your physical energy
your anger your moods your inhibitions
dissolve and it might open up the
pathway to that for payment or payment
rate that you didn't want to get to hear
him I can that becomes like in a Stephen
King book